smiling to camera the leaders of the
brics nations met virtually on thursday
affirming a block which some have
described as an alternative to the g7
representing china brazil south africa
india and russia the nations account for
more than 40 percent of the world's
population
and nearly a quarter of global gdp
the response to russia's invasion of
ukraine was front and center with host
chinese president xi jinping opening the
gathering by criticizing u.s led
sanctions
we urge the world to reject the cold war
mentality and block confrontation oppose
unilateral sanctions and abuse of
sanctions and reject the small circles
built around her germanism at a bricks
business forum he accused nato of
antagonizing russia and said sanctions
had turned the global economy into a
weapon
the comments were echoed by vladimir
putin who made his first major
diplomatic appearance since russia's
invasion of ukraine
only based on honest and mutually
beneficial cooperation can we find
solution to the crisis situation in
world economy because of ill-conceived
egotistical actions of particular
countries putin said russia had recently
increased trade with brics partners
none of whom have supported sanctions
against moscow
china and india are key importance of
russian energy
indian leader narendra modi however
steered clear of mentioning sanctions as
a us ally new delhi is refusing to pick
a side we do not believe that uh for for
uh such as the brics uh should become
platforms for these kind of a
geopolitical contestations
as i said
we see the value of the brics summit
taking place at this time precisely in
enabling us to slow down if not fully
prevent uh what seems to be a
kind of incipient polarization uh in
geopolitics uh the west on the one side
and china and russia on the other side
in a joint declaration the leaders
called for more dialogue between russia
and ukraine and pledged to deepen
cooperation in fighting covert 19
counter-terrorism and economic recovery
china has proposed a free trade bloc
among the five countries and the group
is discussing whether to admit new
members
katrina u al jazeera beijing